I'm a big fan of vertical flip phones
like the Z flip 5 but oo reached out
because they wanted to Showcase their
new find N3 flip and honestly after
looking at all the specs and features
this thing is very impressive holding
both in my hand they are both really
comfortable you guys could see that the
find N3 flip does have a large display
so it's a little bit bigger of a phone
uh we also have some differences in
bezels and with the flip five you have
this kind of bezel that's dark and then
you see the screen protector right there
where on the Oppo you actually don't
notice it at all now the other thing
that I see is that the speaker grills on
the Oppo are much larger there's a lot
more holes there so we're going to do a
speaker comparison in just a little bit
and one thing that I noticed right away
is the creases on the foldable screens
here on the Oppo I cannot see it at all
even moving it around in the reflection
whereas the flip five you definitely
notice it now running my fingers across
I could tell that both of them have it
but the crease is super deep on the flip
compared to a very minimal one that you
can barely feel on the Oppo which is
really nice now the Oppo has their
flexion hinge technology I really like
that on the find end to flip when I made
a video about that one but they have
actually improved it even more so it has
25 % better load bearing strength and
it's very very minimalistic completely
flat design so it's more durable up to
600,000 folds now which will Outlast the
whole phone now as far as the buttons
both of them do feel nice they have your
main buttons on the right hand side the
Oppo has the power button a little bit
lower than on the Samsung but one thing
I like is that the Oppo has a physical
mute switch so you can go to silent mode
with vibrations regular and all the way
to full silent just by adjusting this
Hardware switch now both these do still
use SIM cards as well as eim but the
Oppo actually has dual physical Sims and
dual 5G connection so you can be running
those it's a nice little bonus if you
need that and looking at the back of the
phones we have quite a bit of design
differences now I do like that the flip
5 has this top section it's all black so
that screen is kind of hidden there when
it's shut off but overall I like the
oppo's design um it has this kind of
pearl color that looks really nice with
these thin accents on the hinge instead
of being thick you have The Branding
there and one interesting thing is
instead of just being flat on the back
and the sides we have this massive curve
I think it's the biggest one that you
have with glass that curves into the
edge but then you still have this flat
section right over over here and that
makes the phone feel thinner overall
just makes it slightly more comfortable
than a boxy design now with that you
guys can also see the differences in the
camera bump the flip five has two
cameras right here it's fairly small up
in this corner whereas the Oppo has this
Hasselblad ring here that is thicker it
has a nice little Accent on the side
they call it the cosmos ring design and
it kind of looks like a lens and then
you have three cameras in here now
probably the biggest limitation with
vertical flip phones have been the
cameras here we have two 12 megapixel
cameras a standard and an ultra wide and
then looking at the Oppo here there's a
reason why that module is so large now
this is the first vertical flip phone
that has Flagship level cameras it's
also the first one that has triple
cameras cameras and the first one that
has a telephoto camera and instead of
two 12 megapixel ones we have a 50 megap
main camera with the large sensor we
have a 48 megap ultrawide and a 32 map
telephoto camera built in now as for the
selfie camera we have a 10 megapixel on
the zflip 5 compared to a 32 mapel on
the Oppo and both of them can go wider
like this the Oppo is wider though
and with that one really cool thing is
the Oppo has a 2X mode as well because
you have 32 megapixels instead of 10 and
that is nice if you want less Distortion
or less background more focused on your
face and here is a selfie shot you guys
let me know what you think but punching
in here you definitely see more detail
on the Oppo it's nice that you don't
have a lot of oversharpening in my beard
um so it still looks nice and natural
and then looking at the ultra white
photos right here we definitely have
some differences now you guys saw the
Oppo is labeled Hasselblad they're using
a lot of technology in tuning from that
so you guys could see we have a
difference in a lot of the processing
the Oppo here is keeping a lot of the
shadowing that we see from that window
lighting being behind bade whereas the
Samsung is bringing everything up on his
face so we have that highlight rolloff
right here where his whole face is
really bright and one thing that really
surprised me is if we look out the
window window but I don't think I've
ever seen a phone that actually got
what's outside that bright window so the
HDR like we actually see the sky uh we
see the AC in that little building there
compared to this pure white on the
Samsung and then switching to the main
lens we have 50 megapixel compared to 12
once again difference in the processing
and same thing we see all that Sky there
compared to White and and then a part of
that building and now of course we have
that 2x lens 32 megapixel on the Oppo
compared to having to use digital
cropping and right away even in the
background I see a lot more of that
texture um this time the Samsung is
really cool compared to the Oppo is
staying a little bit more um natural
once again and zooming in here on all
this fine detail you guys could see that
we just have smearing over here compared
to the actual text so it's interesting
how on this phone there's a lot less
artificial processing and sharpening
going on in all of the photos that we've
looked at so far now here's another 2x
shot this time it is outside you guys
let me know which you prefer in terms of
colors and processing but looking at the
fine detail here we have the sign on the
Oppo where I can read everything
including the address even though
there's less artificial sharpening being
added on to compensate and then we have
the Samsung there on the left side we
could still read everything but that is
at 2X and here is a 10x shot which is
actually the maximum that the Samsung
can do even without zooming in you could
see the difference in true detail we
look at the trees right here that look
natural compared to this artificially
kind of sharpened mess and then going
into the details a lot of background
detail but then on the side I mean here
is where you could see a difference you
can actually read everything here
compared to here which looks sharper
once again processing but you can't read
anything at all so if you need to zoom
in and get some detail having that extra
telephoto lens is obviously way better
and the Oppo can actually zoom in to 20
times compared to 10 so here's that
difference in terms of zooming and then
of course you can always crop um on both
and that just shows you the difference
in the detail that you're able to
capture now that telephoto mode is not
only good for getting good detail but
also helps for portraits and I want to
mention that Hasselblad is not just a
logo Oppo actually mapped out
hasselblad's very expensive xcd 30 and
xcd 65 lenses and looked at the bokeh to
make their boka for portrait mode match
those lenses and here is a 1x portrait
kind of this medium lighting you guys
see we have some massive differences the
Samsung once again brought up all the
Shadows his shirt looks kind of gray
compared to having a darker scene which
it is right over there in that corner
and then in the face we have that same
shadow rollof that we saw in the other
location uh compared to being all really
flat and then taking a look at the bokeh
um we have some differences there we
actually have some curves um on this
side you guys let me know what you think
with this one and then switching to this
side right here once again you guys
notice the differences that I already
pointed out but the cool thing is
because we have that telephoto camera we
can actually switch to that lens and now
you guys see we have some Distortion
with the 1X lens which is normal
compared to really nice proportions
using that 2x lens another cool thing as
you can see some bokeh in the background
because of the compression and our
little accent lighting is also more
prominent instead of seeing a lot more
of the background where we have some
stuff on the floor over there now to
show you guys a even better example
we've done this a few times if you
really want to get close up you get some
crazy warping compared to using a 2X
lens which everything looks a lot more
natural and the other thing I noticed
with the Oppo um not only are they
adjusting the colors and the processing
lowering that to make it more natural
but the blur definitely looks a lot more
natural than what you have here where
it's just a bit too much now going into
some nighttime photos we have this 1X
shot right here they both look very s
similar we have some difference in
lighting though and then if we go in and
take a look at the low light performance
definitely cleaner on that larger sensor
with the Oppo bit more detail land
almost no noise that is visible and then
I have one more shot right here of Vadim
this is what some of these lights turned
off using night mode on both and if we
go ahead and take a look there is a big
difference in detail between both of
these so it's definitely nice to have
that higher megapixel count so overall
I'm very impressed with the cameras it's
nice to have a foldable phone that does
not lack in that area and with that the
Hasselblad portrait mode and the tuning
of the colors being a lot more natural
same thing with the HDR a lot more
natural than you see it is definitely
nice and now let's compare the cover
screens as I mentioned with the Samsung
you have that glass on the front so it
kind of Blends in and then when I turn
it on right here we actually see a
little bit info and then we can un lock
it and then now you can swipe through
and there's a couple different things
you could do so here we have our
calendar you have um your weather some
alarms some info for your activity just
some basic things like that some
notification settings and it is cool how
it kind of Blends in and the size is
large but as you guys see it is kind of
like a horizontal screen not typically
what you have on the inside so it's more
of a half of a screen now on the Oppo
you guys see it's not as wide but it is
really tall and the cool thing about
this is it's pretty much like a mini
screen of a phone like back in the day
when you had really small screens and
this vertical layout does give you some
benefits so first off here you know we
have some notifications some widgets you
can swipe down and get to your control
center just like you can on the inside
screen the layout is very similar you
can adjust your brightness and then
notifications from the bottom and then
we go to the side and we have all of
these mini apps so we have a a ton of
different stuff to choose from and
because of that layout makes it easy for
a bunch of third-party apps to just work
on this cover screen we have Google Maps
right here I have not signed into to
that but we can actually go in zoom in
and use this full app just like you
would on the inside we have YouTube
music Gmail your texts and it's
basically the inside just on a smaller
screen and you don't have to open up
your phone to get full access to full
applications and then of course the
cover screen is nice because you can
take selfies with the main cameras using
this mode and as you guys can see I have
a uncropped view with that vertical
display with all of my settings just
like on the inside compared to a basic
one and I mentioned the difference in
the speaker Grill so now let's go ahead
and compare the
[Music]
speakers
all right guys you let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below to
me they sound very similar and now
comparing to displays as you guys see
the Oppo does have a slightly larger 6.8
in display compared to 6.7 now both
these have really nice resolutions they
are sharp both go all the way up to 120
htz so they are very smooth and all the
way down to 1 HZ because they are ltpo
and that helps to save battery power
which is really nice now one difference
that we do have is that opple is now
using a Coe or a CO technology and that
makes it so they have a polarizer free
design on the screen so not only do you
not notice that screen protector but
when you're outside if you're wearing
sunglasses let me go ahead and pop mine
on here the difference is pretty crazy
on a lot of these flip phones or all of
them you actually get this rainbow
effect where the polarizer is um making
a really kind of weird effect with the
polarizer in the screen so it's really
rainbowy very distracting looks weird
well Oppo fixed that with their new
technology and it looks completely
normal just like you were not wearing
sunglasses so that is really nice when
you are outside and it's bright now
another really cool thing is that the
Oppo is using
1,440 Hertz for the pulsewidth
modulation compared to 240 that's a
massive difference so people that have
sensitive eyes to the blinking or
flashing of OLED displays well the Oppo
is going to really help with that
compared to some people that are getting
ice strain and issues like that um with
OLED refresh rates now comparing HDR we
can see that the Samsung does have
brighter uh brights where the HDR is
popping more more so than the Oppo
detail level looks very similar between
both the video footage is nice and
smooth but we do have some differences
in terms of the contrast the saturation
and the tuning with these uh displays
and the HDR playback but in terms of
that brightness I'm not sure why that's
happening because the previous test the
Oppo was brighter Maybe YouTube just
needs to update the app now in terms of
brightness both these have very bright
displays and went ahead and I maxed out
both of them and you as you guys could
see the Oppo in our studio is actually
brighter when you want to crank it up
they allow you to instead of dimming
where you have a large white screen
heading outside the Oppo also looks
brighter when we have a bright display
with a lot of whites but it's
interesting when we go to a page that's
mostly dark that is when the Samsung
actually gets really bright and can hit
its advertising
knits and then going back inside here
with that same page now the oppo's a lot
brighter so the Samsung with its high
brightness rating it's really when
you're in dark mode and outside uh when
you can actually get the benefit of it
compared to the Oppo where they're
giving you to even inside and lighting
like this and now let's talk about
batteries and charging now both of these
phones give you a USB type-c cable to
charge up but of course Sam Samsung does
not give you a charging break anymore
whereas Oppo gives you a charging break
in the box and it is a fast charger now
the interesting thing is that the zflip
5 will charge up to 25 watts compared to
43 wats for the find N3 flip with that
the Z flip 5 has a 3,700 milliamp hour
battery compared to
4,300 Milah so quite a bit more battery
battery capacity and even though the
battery is larger when you are charging
the Oppo will hit 58% charge in 30
minutes compared to
50% so you're not losing out on charging
speeds either so with all that said the
zflip 5 is a great foldable phone but if
you want something that is much more of
a flagship level experience while also
having the ability to fold down become
much more compact the find end 3 flip is
definitely the better phone you have
that large cover screen you have a
triple camera layout with that telephoto
camera a crease that is way less
noticeable as well and a large battery
capacity with this nice design so it's
cool to see uh companies really pushing
forward the design the find and two flip
had a nice big Improvement and now with
the N3 flip they've stepped it up even
more especially with what could do on
the front and its camera capabilities
but you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
video